bye
hey what's going on what's up
what are you doing here what are you
doing here cheating on me hey get out of
my house
go on
jody yeah i bet i bet
she's in you're uh your niece now huh
you're lucky i don't beat your fast
[ __ ] hey what's your name in rank dude
what's your name in rank hey look at the
camera
look at the camera yeah your dude
say goodbye to your rank
so who was in the army he was or she was
i think they all were okay
if you're thinking other cheats on you
i'll go after the dude that's cheating
that
that that she's cheating with that's not
who you got a problem with
y'all need to sit down and have a
conversation so you heard him say the
word jody you know what jody is
jody jody's a term for service members
who bang other service members wives
that's how common it is how what's the
correlation with jody
don't know i can just tell you that's a
term that they use okay that's the term
left to use that's why i called him a
jody
and i look at the other dude clear buzz
cut bad fashion
that's military that's military 100
military i'll take one look at that
obviously military and i think where
they're staying it looks like a pmq
but yeah that's uh that's the
information but yeah what'd you think
about the whole thing
it's common you said it was common okay
so
yeah it's just
the way he chased down the dude and
in the background daddy yeah well
about that but jody's in the marines of
jody's
generalized term meaning any man who
stays at home while everyone else goes
to war
he gets to enjoy all the things marines
are missing more specifically the
marine's girlfriend back at home
while the marine is away on active duty
the reason they're called jody
specifically dates back to
black soldiers in world war ii they took
a character from old blues songs named
joe the grinder
joe d who would steal the ladies of
intimate soldiers and equipped
his name to jody damn that's deep
i don't know how accurate that was
because that's urban dictionary there's
a mad [ __ ]
but hey that's steve thief if that's
true that's the
that wow this is why that's why i said
in that last video
i mean she's going to basic training i
don't know what it is about army life
bro but they be out here just
infidelities crazy and it's even tougher
you know it's another service member you
know why
let me feel free to go ahead i mean i
can understand why
there's emotional you go through the
basic camp it's emotional it's
a lot you're tired you need someone to
reconvert you
dude that's there for that is not there
i mean even when you pass that though
yeah even when you pass that even when
you're passionate past that you know we
pass basic if you're not in a situation
of war
it can get pretty boring so you need to
you know you know you don't know what's
going on you always spend your time
together
these people kind of know you in
situation that your significant other
don't know you like i
i get that i get that it happens yeah
you know what i mean like you you you
are in situation all the time
they gotta have your back you gotta have
your back so it kind of creates a bong
which you don't have to
a choice to stick together when you
stick together while feelings can
develop and whatever whatnot but
yeah i i am surprised that this happened
at all
at all yeah uh as far as like the
reasons like maybe it's what priest said
um maybe then again that's yeah yes yeah
i get it i get what you're saying uh but
it does happen it's common
it's super common that's why when people
tell me about like
marriages or relationships in the
military like a lot of dudes start
chuckling like man if you
don't have a partner who's cheating on
you like you find yourself like a rare
pokemon that's
crazy especially when people want
deployment that's the weird one of
course
i just don't understand i don't
understand he's 28 he's a bum why does
she want him but not me
i don't understand i got good grades i
got a future
i'm like why
and that's what i realized they want
bombs
from that price [ __ ] i changed
everything i got to fade that week and
everything
i started just [ __ ] going crazy i'm
like
fighting making money for the household
getting paid good money
and you out here just taking some other
d it's like going to prison but getting
paid mad money for it
yeah but my money you're getting paid
money for it yeah
there was even a guy who went on
deployment and he found out his girl was
doing prawn while he was away
how how would he not find don't ask me
the logic behind
true don't ask me true why people do
this stupid
just do yeah yeah she didn't just she
broadcasted it to the world yup
yeah yeah yeah good you guys actually
can some of you might have you can see
the video is very popular
i definitely watched it a few times just
for um research
but [ __ ]
yeah but you know you know what's crazy
it was crazy
after he found out and he dumped her she
came back for a second video
which i also researched
[Laughter]
cool yeah send me crazy right send me
the link i want to do some rehab
all right hey listen i'm fast man yeah
you know yeah
yeah you guys are gonna know a lot of
you guys are gonna know there's some men
of culture in the chat and they know
for men of course you know when people
you know you know what's funny when
people say like man
people cheat so much nowadays i'm like
yeah no but then i think about the army
life
like true nowadays it's not nowadays
it's been yeah it's just that yeah
scandalous
scandalous scandalous bro but yeah i
just wanted to share this quick clip
what would you do if you came home when
you seen something like that oh actually
i should give context a story so the guy
the service member
apparently they were thinking of going
through like a separation process but
they haven't finalized it but even if
they were going through like a divorce
process if she had a dude that quickly
wind up
that means that before y'all even agreed
she already had something ready
which means during the relationship she
was doing shady because nobody goes
through that process that fast
and already has another dude so that's
another thing to consider
but me parsley if i walk in i see that
you know what really threw me is like he
walked in and the little girl was on
like a chair and was going daddy
meaning she was not being watched right
much whatever then he goes up the stairs
and he sees her in the bathroom
and there's like an awkward moment of
silence and then the guy just goes he
knows he's
so he leaves because he's being recorded
he gets outside and this man starts
running
this is something weird about the whole
scene yeah he starts booking yeah
[ __ ] we already got you on the camera
just save yourself you don't know what
that cuz
that guy was getting more and more like
physical
physical and so you don't know what's
going what's going to happen in the back
of your head so you don't want to stay
there like a
you know and if you're a civilian if
you're a civilian
and a military wife comes up to you do
not do it stay away
okay because like well i met a lot of
service members who are a little bit
unstable
infidelity can set somebody over the
edge so don't do it especially
considering a lot of them do have
training so it's not working
training ptsd you put training you heard
what i said
they have training and ptsd
you really want to come by that you with
the wrong one
sometimes it's not good for you me percy
if i see this i'm like
i'm filming that taking that to divorce
court trying to see if i can fix
something
just to improve my odds yeah that's what
i would do
yeah i mean i'm just saying okay
that's how it gonna be okay
that's it so tell us how would you guys
handle this situation
what would your reaction be we want to
hear from you in the comments below
[Music]
oh
me